[Music]
all right let's go to monica
in richmond indiana what's up monica
hey john how's it going outstanding how
about you
i'm all right i'm all right
let's let's do this what's up okay so
i'm having issues getting my husband to
open up to me
he's got some mental health issues
a lot of quote unquote demons
that he's trying to work through okay
and
i know there's something troubling him
but he's just not
wanting to open up and talk to me cool
thanks for sharing that so
um how long have you all been married
it'll be two years
in august okay but we've been together
for five okay
and when you say mental health issues or
challenges
what tell me what you're talking about
he's got some adhd
um he's got anxiety and um
bipolar depression okay um
what's bipolar depression where
he will his his days are really good
but then his bad days are bad but he's
not diagnosed bipolar
bipolar no okay the depression
has good days and then really bad days
okay what's a really bad day look like
where um he gets he just clams up
he uses his phone like social media
as a coping mechanism where he will just
scroll
and not talk to anybody not want to do
anything
not want to get up from the bed or the
couch
he just stares at his phone just goes in
the hole huh
yes and what what set this off
um it it varies oh it can be something
minor like hey when i asked him you know
take off the track or can you take out
the trash
and um other times it's his job
sometimes it's a conversation with one
of his family members
it's it's just all over the place
was he doing this before y'all were
married it wasn't as bad
um it just it's it's gotten
so much worse over the last five years
and you don't know has he been doing
this his whole life or this
last five years or six years the
diagnosis
came well he's had adhd since i've ever
known him
yeah and we went to high school together
and um
but the the anxiety and depression have
been diagnosed
over the last i'd say three to four
years okay
[Music]
so two two tracks i want to take here
first track is talk to you
okay okay um
i can't think of a more devastating
loneliness
than loving somebody so much
and them hurting and they don't tell you
how or why they're hurting
and it's like you're standing over a
cave just saying hey we
grab my hand and they're saying no
right and at some point you toggle back
and forth between being really pissed
off
just grab my hand what are you doing and
then you also if you're like most normal
humans maybe not you
you spend a season i must be putting my
hand in wrong
right it's almost this um gaslighting
that's not
words but it's it's in a response to
actions like i must not be
must be my fault if i just knew the
right way to reach down there and grab
them then i could help out
right and it feels so lonely is that
ring a bell at all
a little bit yes and i was like i know
there's something some way i can help
him
okay i'm a fixer yes but i know i
i i can't fix everybody but i want to
help as much as i can
yeah okay so
this is especially fun for fixers right
so the most important thing you can know
is that him
taught not talking to you him not
opening up with you him not
being transparent with you isn't about
you
and fixers really struggle with that
because in their mind everything is
about them and they can just solve
pretty much any problem if you'll just
let me see all the parts to it i'll put
the puzzle together i just need all the
pieces well
i've learned that i can't do that i've
learned to cut it towed it back but i'm
still
it's still hard for me well and here's
the thing your head knows that but your
heart doesn't
right and so what you are going to start
doing is you're going to start getting
anxious
and you're going to start like anxiety
and depression are on the same trend
line
right i don't like them even as two
different diagnostics because they just
work together so closely
and so um you are going to begin
to find yourself if you haven't already
being super frustrated and you
start just scrolling or you just start
checking out or you
right you'll find yourself there because
there's a disconnect between what you
know in your head this isn't about me
and your body is looking at this person
you love completely shutting everybody
else out
right and that begins to wear on your
soul right
so here's one or two things you can do
as a fixer that's not gonna make you
feel good as a fixer
but it's the best you can get okay okay
and i want you to think of his life in
and i got this from emily nagaski from a
series of ons and offs
because people who have deep anxiety
people are struggling with depression
it's a physical safety issue
most of the time so there is something
in his head
something in his body that is saying you
are not safe right now
you are not something about his
ecosystem is saying you're out of
control
you don't know what's coming next you're
disconnected and so what folks do
is they pick up their phone and stare at
it right they go have another drink and
another drink and another drink they go
meet another
another um lady another guy to make them
like it
ban it you know band-aids over this fear
that they have that they're not meeting
up at home right so
all of a sudden um this and then uh what
does that do
it just compounds the disconnection and
it compounds that
that you're not safe and the internet
will tell you whatever you want to
what whatever you want to know so if
you're scared about something it will
magnify that fear right and it just goes
on and on and on right
so what are some ways you can create
as safe a home as possible at the same
time not becoming a doormat
so what you're looking to do is not fix
him
you're looking to create safety
create peace right and then
he may say that's uh i'm
um i think i want to talk about this now
okay
so what does that look like sitting down
with him and saying hey you know what
i've been driving you crazy about this
whole thing
i know you're struggling i'm not gonna
bother you with anymore i trust that you
love me enough that when you're ready to
talk
um you know i'm here
and you know i'll go to the ends of the
earth for you
in the meantime what are some things
around here that i could do
to help make this a more peaceful home
for you to come to
what are some things around here i can
do to
um not tell you
not hassle you not fix you but
to let you feel that you're loved around
here
and monica this is critical
because this is the moment when people
become codependent they become doormats
and you've got to go do the work on you
what does that mean that means you have
to go
talk to a professional because you're
married to somebody
who is not doing well and
at some point they're choosing to not do
well right
because there is healing if you wanted
to go down that road and right now he's
not choosing that road
he's not choosing you but he's not
choosing to get well right
and you're still going to invite him to
the concert and he's just
ignores you or says i'm not going that's
when you say cool i'm taking susan and
we're going
because at some point you've got to
begin to do the things that make you
feel well
make you connected you choosing to
disconnect from your world
because he doesn't want you to ends up
making everybody sick it drowns the
whole house does that make sense
yes so go to church even if he won't go
go to the concert even if he doesn't
want to go be the change you want to see
in your home
right grab books and read about this
stuff if he does go see a counselor ask
hey can i come with you
and if he says absolutely not say cool
i'm gonna go to my appointment
why do you need to go to counseling you
need to go you're fine well i live with
someone who's struggling and so i
have to learn about me right that's when
you are doing these things you are
making sure that
you are whole and well right
and then the next part of this whole
conversation is him and so this is me
talking to
anybody who feels like their only friend
is their cell phone
the only safe place is on a couch or
under your covers
please don't choose that life
and i am intentional about that language
i know there are days people cannot get
out of bed
they can look at someone who cares about
them and say help please
they can make that call even if it's an
online therapist they can make that
phone call
folks who are struggling and i've been
cr i've been crippled with anxiety
to where i could hardly move there was a
lot of lifestyle choices i could i ended
up having to make
there are relationships i had to reach
out to that were super uncomfortable
super awkward super weird there are
seasons when i've been in i didn't want
to get out of bed i didn't want to do
and you get up out of bed or you reach
out and you call someone and say hey i'm
struggling getting up
i need some help right and so there is a
responsibility there
even when you think you can't do it
there is a responsibility
to open your eyes and say help me or put
both feet on the floor and take one step
and then take one more step if you're so
anxious and spun out
make that phone call and go see somebody
and say help please
please help and i want everyone
listening to know
there is light on the other side of that
tunnel there is
and it's often sometimes the avenue that
help is
sitting there right in your house like
monica here right
so monica if we had to step back and say
what is that the heightened point of
tension
what are the points that are just kind
of rattling your marriage right now
um what would they be
well it's it's lack of communication is
a big one
um you know lack of help around the
house as well
um i'm working two jobs now because
we're following the dave ramsey plan
and um you know i'll i'll put like
[Applause]
you know dogs need to be fed and trash
needs taken out
on our dry erase board at home as like a
hey he's kind of neat done
um could you help me out kind of kind of
that message i'm going for
and um i'll put a little
love you kisses type little sign off on
it
to let him know that i'm that i love him
and um
you know if i come home and he's sitting
on the couch on his phone
not paying attention to our two-year-old
i'll kind of be like hey
did did you at least get anything done
he's like no
yeah and then i i get irritated i've
been trying not to
you know lash out at him or you know as
soon as i walk through the door
and i see him i've been trying not to be
like hey did you get all this done
i'm trying to work on myself and say
you know hey how was your day and then
walk those questions in
are you um
when's the last time you went on a date
it has been a hot minute when's the last
time y'all had
um or anything other than
perfunctory like duty
like intimate um
[Music]
well intimacy is a
few and far between it's
he he he also uses sex as a coping
mechanism
and so there's a lot of
you know taking on his part on that
but not a lot of giving for me
so i feel a little bit used in that area
so i i don't really
monica not a little bit you feel a lot
used okay yeah okay
yeah right and then it starts the big
cycle because absolutely you're not a
jungle gym
and you're not his blankie and at the
same time
his his challenges are craving
connection
and he doesn't know how to do that
verbally he doesn't know how to do that
respectfully and that's the one
connective outlet he's got right
yes um so i'm gonna be as honest as i
can with you
um your marriage is in a lot of trouble
am i fair yes okay
um i think it's fair for him to know
that
because i know he feels that i know you
feel that it's full of your house
it feels like you are more his mom right
now than his wife you
are more his caretaker than his lover
yes right and absolutely that's a
dangerous dance to get into because it's
really hard to get out of that
right because nobody wants to hook up
with her mom and nobody wants to
be romantic with their son right right
and or if that's a gross analogy for you
nobody not for you but for the listener
nobody wants to
i don't even go down that road so y'all
y'all are in a dangerous dance it's a
cycle and it goes spit it'll spin faster
and faster and faster
and it has been over the last five years
right
so at some point someone's got to turn
the lights on turn the music off and say
i'm done with this dance
because here's the thing most people
don't stop the dance because they're
worried about what's going to happen
and what i'm going to tell you is what's
going to happen is going to happen
anyway this marriage ends up in ashes
anyway and you just lose a lot of years
of your life
somebody's got to flip the lights on say
whoa
what's going on here
i need everybody to go get into a
marriage counselor's office tomorrow
right i'm not gonna live
in a desire-free marriage any longer i
deserve more than that
you deserve more than that i'm not gonna
watch the mean that i love
just wilt away in the floor of our
living room with a cell phone
i'm not a girl or boy little boy little
girl
little boy little boy i'm not gonna let
my son grow up thinking that this is
what
partnership looks like that this is what
marriage looks like that this is what
fatherhood looks like i refuse
right right how close are you to
calling it i have been
within a hair's length
before and it's we'll have our
our good good days and then something
bad will trigger it
and you know he'll make me mad and
i'll just start thinking of you know
all the past stuff that he's done how
it's all piled up
and then i'll be like okay well next
time it's the last time that i'm doing
this so i'm done
and then he'll be really sweet and it'll
be like we're fine we're perfectly fine
until the cycle starts starts again
monica you are
you are teetering over the edge of
resentment and you know what i think
about resentment
yes you are real real close
i have i have been on the edge of
resentment with him before
oh okay it was so hard to come back from
that so listen here's where you're at
choose the right time the right moment
do not do it in a fight
do not do it on the heels of a
disagreement or when he forgot to take
out the trash
or that's when he chose not to take out
the trash right
right set up a moment set up a breakfast
set up a lunch
get some child care and say hey we gotta
have this conversation now
worth this you're worth this we are
worth this our
baby's worth this
everybody involves life is worth more
than what y'all are
giving it right you need to be married
to somebody who cherishes the ground you
walk on who desires you who goes to war
for you who laughs with you who you
don't have to write chores on a
whiteboard for
right and he deserves to have a wife
that is all
in that can't wait to get home
man man man
if you're out there i'm looking at you
if you're out there and you're
struggling anxiety you're struggling
with depression
call somebody today do not drown
on your own don't don't you can make the
call
you may not be able to get out of bed
you can make that call
if you were somebody whose cell phone is
more important to you than your wife
put it away if you're somebody whose
cell phone is more important than your
kids
throw it off your roof
throw it off your roof your kids aren't
worth your cell phone your husband's not
worth your cell phone
they're not
if you are teetering on the edge of
resentment stop the dance
if you are spinning out of control stop
the dance somebody turn off the music
somebody turn on the lights and say
i'm worth more than this you're worth
more than this let's
stop and figure this out
and if one of them says well screw you
i'm out of here listen they're out of
there anyway
they were out of there anyway
i hate that for you monica my heart's
broken for you turn the lights on man
turn off the music and let's have that
conversation
write me back let me know how that goes
and we'll let the listeners know how
that conversation goes
it's gonna be a hard one and it may not
go great
you're gonna have to have an or what
plan if he says we'll screw you i'm not
doing anything you're gonna have to have
an order what plan
i know that you already have one
actually i know you do